So, the answer to this question is 0.675 or 1350 divided by 2,000. And 0.325
or 650 divided by 2,000. Now hopefully, you noticed a nice pattern here is that
the frequencies for these two alleles should add up to one always. No matter how
many alleles we have, when we calculate
the allele frequency, they should all add back
up to one. Now, how do we get this answer? Well, we see here that we have 500
po, plus alleles, and we have another 500 alleles in
that same homozygous group, right? 500 people
that are homozygous dominant are actually 1,000
alleles of the dominant allele. Then we
have 350 heterozygous individuals, 350 more dominant alleles.
So that equals 1,350 total. 1,350 divided by 2,000 gives us 0.675. The recessive
allele would be 150 and another 150 because of the homozyous condition,
right? And then 350 in the heterozygous condition. So this is a total of 650
recessive alleles. And we divide it by 2,000 to get 0.325 for
the allele frequency of the recessive allele.